[Music]
straight ahead
all law and crime daily the defense team
of robert durst files an emergency an
indefinite stay of trial
why attorneys say the millionaire real
estate heir accused of murdering his
best friend
is physically incompetent to stand trial
we speak to a juror in the trial of a
convicted wife killer scott peterson
about a possible retrial what he has to
say about allegations of stealth juror
tainted
deliberations my mind hasn't changed one
bit
and what to expect for the upcoming iowa
trial of a man accused of killing a
college student and hiding her body in a
cornfield
plus a former florida deputy on trial
for allegations
of planting drugs on unsuspecting
motorists takes a stand in his own
defense
zachary wester's explanation for drugs
found in his own patrol car
i was processing evidence from a call
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
attorneys for a millionaire real estate
heir charged in the murder of his best
friend
are asking for an emergency stay in his
trial which is set to resume
next week the evidence will show
demonstrating that
she was unafraid she wasn't scared
she didn't know what was going to happen
and then she was executed
robert dur's trial in the death of a
long time friend susan berman began last
year
and was halted amid the pandemic over
three days
prosecutor john lewin argued in opening
statements that berman's death in 2000
had a direct link to the disappearance
of robert durst's wife
kathleen durst in 1982 and used the
death of his neighbor
morris black in 2001 to tie all three
incidents
together susan berman although loyal
was not the best at keeping secrets but
robert durst defense team denies he had
anything to do
with his wife's disappearance or susan
berman's murder
the entire case is premised on a false
assumption and a false presentation
not only is there evidence which
completely belies
the prosecution's case but you will see
they have no
evidence as how to how this alleged
murder
of kathy durst ever occurred bob durst
did not
kill susan burma he doesn't know who did
durst attorneys say their client wants
to take the stand at his trial
but his bladder cancer and other health
conditions make him physically
incompetent to proceed
attorney david chestnoff and his team
filed this emergency motion to continue
the trial
the judge is expected to hear their
arguments on monday
joining us today is former federal
prosecutor gene rossi and terry austin
gene the judge needs to balance the jury
being out for 14 months in a request
for an indefinite delay due to dura's
competency how do you see the judge
ruling here
i think the judge is going to continue
the trial i had a doctor pain doctor
who had a medical issue very serious and
the judge
continued it for two or three months but
it was an illness that was much less
serious
than bladder cancer and the other thing
is this mr dirtz
is set almost 79 years old and just look
at that photo or the video right there
it doesn't look well and i think the
judge is going to continue it
definitely yeah now terry the defense
wants durst released to a medical
facility where durst can get
treatment uh kind of seems like a like a
compromise here do you think the judge
may
rule that way listen i think that would
be a great compromise brian i hope
they're listening to you
this case needs to go to trial like gene
said durst is 78 years old
and he does have a medical condition but
this case has been going on
this occurred in 2000 when he allegedly
killed susan berman which it seems
evidence is pointing in that direction
so i think they should figure out a way
to have
this case actually be tried so that we
can have some justice
even though this justice is clearly
delayed yeah i don't think the judge is
really going to like this concept of
it being an indefinite delay if there is
some sort of time period
maybe but i think it's going to give the
judge some pause we'll see how that
works out though
and now to a major interview with a
juror in the trial of convicted wife
killer scott peterson
law and crime's angela levy spoke with
one of the jurors about peterson's claim
that a stealth juror tainted
deliberations
yeah brian scott peterson is asking for
a new trial based in part
on a potential issue with one of the
jurors but juror mike belmussieri
says that more than 16 years later he
has no regrets about the verdict
he's where he deserves to be he earned
it mike belmezzieri is one of the 12
jurors who spent nine months listening
to evidence in the trial of scott
peterson
he says he went into the trial believing
peterson was innocent
and was unaffected by the massive amount
of publicity
where scott peterson was concerned yeah
there was no reason for me to believe he
was guilty because i didn't know
anything i didn't pay any attention to
anyone
but over the months as prosecutors
presented more
evidence bel messieri says a clear
picture began to emerge
of a man who wanted to be free of the
responsibilities of a wife
and baby the bodies of lacey and connor
peterson were found a short distance
from where peterson had gone fishing
in the san francisco bay on christmas
eve 2002.
peterson used a small boat that day it
had been purchased two weeks prior
he committed a very heinous crime and
there's no doubt in my mind by the way
that that's the case
now peterson wants a new trial he says
juror rachelle niece nicknamed
strawberry shortcake by the media
lied on her juror questionnaire about
being the victim of domestic violence
and seeking a restraining order
let's talk about uh strawberry shortcake
peterson claims niece was a stealth
juror who went into deliberations with a
clear agenda to convict him
bel messieri says nice had a strong
opinion and was brought into the
deliberations later as an alternate
she didn't in any way uh influence
anyone
with her her position and uh she finally
you know hey calm down let's talk about
what we're doing we need to start over
and mike belmessieri says that he was
incredibly disappointed when he found
out that rochelle neese had started
writing to scott peterson in prison he
called it completely inappropriate
there's actually a status hearing for
scott peterson's trial late next month
at that time
the attorneys on both sides are expected
to discuss discovery issues
brian thanks ange terry does the
conviction seem
strong based on this juror's conviction
that they got it right
it does seem strong brian and i hope it
holds up
they had a ton of evidence they know
that the body
showed up not far from where he was you
know that day
fishing and that's not just a
coincidence we had a dog who had
tracking evidence we had a hydrologist
who is a water expert
who said that peterson dumped connor's
body from the fishing boat so even
if they have to do this over again i
think there is plenty of evidence and
that juror definitely sounded as though
he thought that it was definitive and
that all the other jurors were on the
same page
so let's hope that it sticks if the
evidence shows it and
clearly it looks like the evidence shows
that this should have been a conviction
now gene let's look at on the other side
does belmont series words about
uh jury niece strengthen any kind of
argument for misconduct
absolutely and here's the thing the
strawberry shortcake miss
nice okay that's a juror that could have
been
a hold out that is a juror that could
have said
not guilty they didn't meet their burden
so scott peterson
in that sense was denied his due process
rights to a fair trial
the other juror mr mike b can't
pronounce his last name
he may the other jurors may feel like he
did but that one juror strawberry
shortcake
could have replaced somebody that could
have said you know what
they didn't meet their burden and that's
not fair
yeah it's not fair you can't have your
cake and eat it too even if it's a
strawberry shortcake
and jeanette does belmonsiri believe
scott peterson deserves a new trial
you know i i asked him that he actually
said that's not up to him he said that
is up to the court
but sitting through all of that months
of testimony he believed
that it all added up all the pieces fit
together that
scott peterson planned this murder all
right so if
he believes it all adds up this might
come down to an
issue that we always talk about uh that
it could just be
harmless error because at the end of the
day if all of them believe that the
evidence
fit the facts and the facts fit a guilty
verdict
maybe we'll see another another uh trial
but we'll have to wait and see
thank you everyone still ahead on law
and crime daily the former deputy on
trial
takes a stand in his own defense but
first opening statements in the trial of
an iowa college student found murdered
in a cornfield
are set to next week everything you need
to know after this break
welcome back a man accused of killing an
iowa college student is set to stand
trial
next week our own angela levy will be in
iowa for the trial
and is here with what to expect
brian christian behena rivera is charged
with first-degree murder in the killing
of molly tibbetts she was a college
student from
iowa and they say the prosecutors say
that
haina rivera led them to tibbetts's body
but his attorneys say he's actually
innocent
i received a call at home probably
around 9
30 at night from sheriff kriegel
advised me that one of our deputies was
looking into the disappearance of a of a
young lady named molly tibbetts in
brooklyn
university of iowa student molly
tibbetts was dog sitting on july 18
2018 while her friends were out of town
the only thing really missing or out of
place would have been
her running shoes and we found out
through some interviews that it was
very common for her to go jogging in the
evening officers say tibbetts is last
seen on surveillance video jogging
as a black chevrolet malibu with chrome
mirrors and door handles circles the
area
investigators pulled over a car matching
that description
and spoke with the driver christian
bahano rivera
police say bahina rivera agreed to take
them to the body
after an 11 hour interrogation we had
mr averick exit my car and
walked him back to where we had gone
into the corn field we
knew that we needed to kind of change
our position a little bit
and once we once we did after that
second set of instructions from him she
was found within
a few minutes police say rivera
confessed to arguing with mollie
tibbetts
they say there was blood in the back of
his car but his lawyers say it didn't
belong to tibbetts
the officer who questioned rivera failed
to read rivera his full miranda rights
the first time around
so the jury won't see some of that
evidence bahina rivera's lawyers say his
statement isn't reliable because of the
language barrier
and because the interrogation went on so
long you saw signs
that mr bohena was tired on that video
probably yeah
you saw times where he actually fell
asleep didn't you
yes yes
and the judge in this case moved the
trial an hour and 40 minutes
away from where this crime actually took
place because of so much pre-trial
publicity
jury selection in the case is expected
to take two days and opening statements
are set
for may 19th brian thanks again back
with us is former federal prosecutor
gene rossi and terry austin
gene the defense is saying there was a
language barrier in this 11-hour
interrogation
with rivera while the prosecution is
saying they got a confession
how do you see this interrogation it all
depends on what the evidence is at a
pretrial ruling
uh they're gonna argue that it wasn't a
voluntary statement
and it wasn't knowing and looking at
that maybe he was under fatigue
and and so they have an argument based
on language
and also fatigue and it could be
a case where the judge may flip a coin
if you will
because that that would that would
obviously be grounds for keeping it out
language fatigue
uh the time frame and how long the
interrogation was those are all
certain elements to a false confession
let's see how they plan that out
terry at the end of the day though
rivera led them to her body isn't that
just a closed case
it seems like it's a case close to me as
far as i'm concerned brian i mean
obviously that confession and that
interrogation in 11 hours
could be questioned and really the
authority should have looked at that a
little bit better so that
this individual wouldn't get away
technically with murder because that's a
real distinct possibility here
but the fact that he led them to the
body that means he was involved in the
killing
it means he could have done the killing
and the evidence seems to point to the
fact there was blood in the car
that he did do the killing so hopefully
this evidence
will be admitted and we'll be able to
have some justice in this case
yeah is he the principal person who
committed this crime or an accomplice
not quite sure we'll see how it gets
argued out and jeanette why has this
case received so much attention
well you had a young college student who
just seems like the girl next door who
goes out running and goes missing so
the entire community was out looking for
her so was her family
and a lot of people on the national
level tried to make a lot of the
the fact that bahina rivera was an
undocumented
immigrant and was in this country
potentially illegally
so he was living in iowa but they say he
was
undocumented and some people really
tried to use that for political
advantage
and molly tibbetts parents said they
didn't want any part of that they don't
want her
murder being used in that way so that's
part of the reason it got so much
attention so it's not just the law but a
bit of politics bringing this to the
forefront
makes sense let's check in with jesse
webber host of the law and crime show
prime crime to see what he's working on
this week hey brian yeah it's the case
that changed
everything teenager michelle carter is
charged with killing her boyfriend by
pressuring him to commit suicide through
phone conversations now the text
messages themselves are outrageous
but wait till you hear her police
interview she left out some pretty
important details
did he tell you he was going to do that
or anything like that
[Music]
he was talking about it for a while to
watch our breakdown of the conclusion of
this arguably
unprecedented case tune in to law and
crime
thanks jesse coming up on law and crime
daley a florida deputy accused of
planting drugs
an unsuspecting driver takes the stand
in his own defense
the direct examination on the other side
of this break
[Music]
welcome back a former florida deputy
accused of planting drugs on
unsuspecting motorists is taking the
stand in his own defense
zachary wester is facing 67 charges
including racketeering possession of a
controlled substance
and false imprisonment prosecutors say
wester would ask to search a person's
car
during routine traffic stops and then
place meth or other drugs unlawfully
sending them to jail
on the stand wester had a simple
explanation for why narcotics
and other paraphernalia were found in
the back of his own patrol vehicle
there were plastic canisters
those are what we refer to as evidence
valves anytime you had a powder
narcotic or if you had a crystallized
narcotic
it would be appropriate to place that
into the evidence biles
vials to preserve the integrity of the
narcotics the narcotics mainly had the
appearance
of methamphetamine and marijuana
and i was separating the narcotics the
contents from the bag
putting the narcotic the suspected
narcotics into the clear evidence file
my plan was in one bag to put the
suspected narcotics
in another bag put the paraphernalia so
that the evidence custodian could
dispose of those
items and i proceeded into the sheriff's
office
and wester gave the jury another simple
explanation for why his body camera was
turned off during the stop of a motorist
he arrested for drug possession
the charges against the motorists were
later dropped
whatever investigator would arrive
um it was customary and per policy to
turn off any recording
devices and were you guys going to
discuss something about mr clinty
yes so the conversation that we were
going to have about mr clinty was
possibly
uh what's the objection overall
you can continue okay so the
conversation we were going to have about
mr clinton was possibly
transitioning him to a confidential
informant
and was mr clint ever made a
confidential information that ever
brought up with him he was not
he was on active state probation
and it was my understanding it was very
difficult to allow someone to be a
confidential informant if you were
on probation
when we come back cross-examination how
a wester holds up when it's the
prosecution asking the questions
the fiery testimony ahead
back now to florida where prosecutors
had tough questions for a former deputy
accused of planting drugs during traffic
stops
well why weren't we able to see the
first part of that stop
that's what i'm asking about right yes
sir so i don't work for axon i'm not an
exon body camera technician so all i can
testify to
is the facts of what took place in that
particular incident
where it it appeared to experience what
we were told in our training as a reset
function and the body camera was
unable to start recording and as soon as
it got to a spot
to where the camera was rebooted and i
could restart the video
i did that as soon as possible and it so
happened that that error occurred at the
time that you would have first gotten in
that car and first had the opportunity
to see the syringe and the baggy isn't
that right i would disagree with that
that's not when the error occurred i
would disagree with that
then why isn't it on the video mr
williams i've explained this to you
three or four times now as far as why
that is not on the video
when the prosecution put pressure on the
defendant wester stood his ground
saying all of the searches were lawful
i did and here's the thing every time i
pulled someone over
if they said oh that's mom or that's
dads or that's my cousins
there would never i can't say never the
majority of the time
there would not be an arrest made in a
narcotics possession case most of the
time
they deny knowledge so mr williams
you're presenting to this jury that in
the first circuit where you work
that if someone says that they didn't
know about the narcotics you're just
going to drop the case on every single
narcotics charge that comes on your desk
there you know that's not what i'm
saying it sounds to me that's what
you're saying
okay well thank you for your input now
that is what is an issue in this case to
this jury is to determine whether or not
those drugs were really there or whether
or not you put them there
i would agree that is the issue right
and i'm testifying to this jury today
that the drugs were there i did not put
the narcotics here
all right let's bring in gene and terry
one last time gene what did you make of
wester's explanation of the drugs
in his vehicle oh this is simple
he was suspended august 1st of 2018.
he was suspended okay they probably said
you can't do your job anymore
this search of his car i believe was
september
6th why in god's name
is meth still in his car there is
no law enforcement reason for that meth
to be there
unless it had been there because he was
planting it
that would be my argument to the jury
and this explanation he was doing his
chain of custody preserving the
integrity that's baloney
when you seize the drugs from somebody
during a car stop
you do a bee line to the police station
and you put it in evidence and it's
called chain of
custody and and for him to have all that
in his car
his explanation doesn't pass the laugh
test that's a big
achilles heel in his defense absolutely
let's hope the prosecution is explaining
it as clear as you did
terry i don't know whether this was too
grown men bickering or a
cross-examination
was a cross-examination effective here i
actually think it was
effective yes they were bickering but
this was the most
arrogant argumentative witness i've ever
seen on the stand actually i mean he was
really
being contrite with the prosecution and
while i think the prosecution should
have limited
the testimony he should have said to the
judge listen judge he's not answering
the question make him answer the
question non-responsive et cetera
i do think that the prosecution held his
ground
and i think he made western look uh or
the
witness look like he was arrogant and
and defensive and i think the jury is
not going to like him for that so
good job on the prosecution side yeah
definitely a lot of bad facts against
wester we'll see how this plays out
terry and jean thank you very much and
thank you for joining us here at law on
crime daily we'll see you next time as
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you